my first allegiance is what will be best
for the philadelphia eagles and our fans
for the next
three four five years
it's not based on does someone deserve
to hold their job or deserve to get
fired that's a different bar
very few people probably after success
deserve
to lose their job
this is much more about the
evaluation of whether the eagles
moving forward our best option is to
have a new coach
and that that's really really what it's
about
it's not about did doug deserve to be
let go no he did not deserve to be let
go that's not
where i'm coming from and that's not the
bar in the evaluation process
i want to give eagles owner jeffrey
lurie the benefit of the doubt there if
that's the best you can do
to explain the decision to fire a guy
who just won a super bowl three years
ago maybe you shouldn't be firing a guy
who won a super bowl three years ago or
maybe you should not
be telling us that there's got to be
more to this well that's
that's what it is that's what it is
exactly
that's a lot more exactly he's being
careful he's
that's that's what it seems like to me i
mean
it explains like it it doesn't make
sense any of it
three out of five years you've gone to
the playoffs you know three of the last
four years
you won a super bowl three years ago all
of that
nothing lines up to what that deserves
to get fired there has to be other
there has to be other stuff to the story
and i think that's some of the stuff you
and i have heard behind the scenes
i don't know the exactness of all that
but
there's obviously an issue there with
where the organization did not
like where doug peterson's vision
was for the future of the organization
and didn't just like some of his answers
apparently
as far as how the organization was being
run right now that's that's kind of what
it
sounds like to me and i don't know that
vision is all that accurate either
vision just may be the buzzword that
somebody came to
put the candy coating on
whatever dysfunction is beneath
it could it just be personality
conflicts it's
and what's amazing to me is we heard the
phrase from jeffrey lurie five years ago
when chip
kelly was fired after only three seasons
on the job
emotional intelligence and it it created
this sense that doug peterson is this
savant when it comes to interpersonal
skills and
he knows how to connect properly and now
maybe it's just chip kelly was so bad
you just have to be a little bit better
to be viewed
as some expert in how to properly get
along with people maybe after time it
just didn't work maybe
maybe people changed after they won a
super bowl maybe doug peterson as
plenty of coaches do as they gain
success they try to secure more power
and influence within the building
maybe there's something to that look all
of this is fair game for us
because they are selling us something
that
feels incomplete at best
fabricated at worst and the other side
of it too is chris
and and this is not an insignificant
part
jeffrey lurie wants doug peterson to get
one of these other jobs because jeffrey
lurie owes doug peterson two years of
salary and if doug peterson just goes
home and does nothing
he gets paid every dollar he would have
gotten paid if he'd still been the coach
of the
eagles he wants him to land somewhere
else larry does
because then he's off the hook possibly
for all of it
if at least not if all of it depending
upon what kind of a deal
peterson would get elsewhere most of it
that's part of it too
so he didn't deserve to be fired he's a
great coach i hope he gets another job i
recommend him to anyone who
anyone else who wants to hire him
because i'd prefer not to have to pay
him for two years to not work i think
that is part of it as well
well i'm sure you know look i i think
jeffrey lurie's a good person and he
he also is you know recognizes what doug
peterson did for the organization i mean
it was
special as far as winning their first
super bowl ever
with a backup quarterback all of those
things so i think he'll
be forever indebted you know to him in
in some sort of way or fashion but like
i i come back to like what kind of what
you're saying though
you know i i don't think is i don't
think this is just
one thing you know i i think this has
got to be a lot of
answers or actions that are not liked
to come to this type of decision there
that's where i think jeffrey luery
that's why his
words are very measured you know deserve
yeah
no i mean a lot of people don't deserve
things you know the the you know
the kid who's starving in the world what
did he deserve to not have
you know food and do things like that
nothing so
you know it's just one of those
situations though where
i i mean i i just think there's a lot of
issues there
and that's what i've been led to believe
as far as
you know people i know behind the scenes
and and not that i've gotten the exact
answers and conversations there but
that's what i've been kind of led to
believe by people in the know
and uh it just kind of seems what what
it is with the way jeffrey lurie's
answering the questions too
never unders underestimate the power of
the billionaire's privilege as well
we have to remember that you're you're
the you're the person who owns the team
you
run the team he's around the team if
there's something that you
see that you don't like and it festers
and it grows and it builds
and you just you know i just don't like
him anymore i mean that
hey these are still human beings walking
around
with all this money at the core they are
human there is a fundamental change in
the existence i think once you acquire
that
amount of wealth and influence and power
but you're still
just the guy like anyone else and at
some level
he may have just decided i don't like
this guy anymore
i used to like him i don't like him i
don't like the way he talks to me
i don't like the way he coaches the team
and there's somebody else out there that
i think could
could could do better and that's the
other side of this too
you know there's two different ways
coaches get fired at the nfl level or
really at
any level one i'm just fed up with this
person and done with this person and
you're gone
and i'll go find someone else anyone i
find i can throw a rock and hit somebody
who would be better than this guy
go that's one way the other way is you
know i have a coach
but there's somebody else that
i think i can hire who would be better
how do we make it happen well step one
you gotta fire the guy that you have
step two
you hire the guy that you wanna hire and
i'd say
most owners go into these processes
knowing damn well who they want and for
something like this when you're talking
about doug peterson after three straight
playoff appearances
after a super bowl championship the
first ever for the franchise
three years later to be fired it
tells me that jeffrey lurie knows
exactly who he's going to hire chris you
think so i i just
i mean i i understand that they they
probably have you know some guys they
got their eyes on
but i think he knows exactly who he's
going to hire
that's just that that gut it's a it's a
pasta and meatballs thing that just
occurred to me yeah it's a gut thing
that just occurred to me as we've talked
this through
this happens not because jeffrey lurie
says doug peterson is unfit to be the
coach
because he's not unfit to be the coach
this happens because there's somebody
else that jeffrey lurie wants and the
window is open to go get that person
that's my belief based on just talking
circumstantial evidence and gut feeling
yeah well i mean listen i don't doubt
that i don't i mean you know
a smart organization would already have
you know that plan
you know set in motion to a degree if
you know you're gonna make that but i
don't think it's what ult
i i don't think it lines up at least to
what we've seen
to where i think that was the ultimate
reason for the decision
we heard these rumors before the season
was over
and i think we all kind of went like ah
there's no way they'll do that there's
no way
but it's one of those now that you look
back at it you go oh
no no there there's something there and
again because of the resume everything
you've said
doug peterson's done nothing you know
to embarrass the eagles as far as like
it's not like he's handled himself
improperly or done anything wrong that
way
to where that's where i just look at it
and go something doesn't make sense and
they're
they're off they're not on the same page
whatever it is
the eagles jeffrey luery howie roseman
they didn't like
where this was going with doug peterson
i think it's just plain and simple and i
don't
what i'm interested in this dude is
where does it go from that from
from here does he get a job and
who takes over philadelphia do you
really want the philadelphia job right
now
that's that's the other thing i would
say about that's why it was a little
risky to fire him
this is not a job like everyone's like
oh please let me take over the jalen
hurts carson wins situation
and be in a total disaster right as i
come into the nfl
please please me i mean from that aspect
right there
the job's towards the bottom of the list
because of that crap you got to deal
with
i want to try to thread this needle a
little bit harmonize the various things
we've been discussing it's possible that
the relationships when you talk about
jeffrey lurie doug peterson and howie
roseman and remember harry roseman's
background is
he's the guy who got thrown out of the
main part of the building when chip
kelly was there and somehow staged a
second act of his career
where he got himself back in there's
been no discussion about howie roseman
being in trouble there's been no
discussion about a new gm
and he wasn't involved yesterday he's
i think clearly safe and that did come
up yesterday from jeffrey lurie howie
roseman's going to be there
and it may just be plain and simple as
doug peterson was having success
he was flexing his muscles internally he
was trying to
develop more influence and power and he
was getting nowhere
he was still being treated the way that
he was his first couple of years on the
job and
from his perspective you look at him say
i want a super bowl come on i mean are
you not going to listen to me i'm a
super bowl winning coach
this is bs that that may have just been
one of the things that
led to right that led to you know and
here's how we harmonize it we started
hearing the rumors and rumblings late in
the season that may have been the point
where jeffrey laurie and possibly
howie roseman together decided here's
who our next coach is going to be
and we just need to wait until after the
season to implement the plan and that's
and that's you know let's get we get
through the season we don't make the
playoffs
and and we we you know we find a way to
artfully extricate
from doug peterson and then we go hire
the guy we want to hire now the question
is
and you're right who wants that job
unless it's somebody who's already kind
of wink nod yeah i'll take it right
it is a tough situation because number
one it's a tough market
the media is not going to be friendly
the fans are going to be skeptical
even though they wanted as far as i
could tell
they wanted this change they were upset
they just wanted something like we're
just
upset we want something okay you're
getting a new coach well who's the coach
going to be how do we know he's going to
be any better what if he's worse well
you wanted something you got something
so it's not going to be an easy spot
forever takes that job i agree with you
i
you know i did a ranking last week of
the of the jobs and
i had top three chargers jaguars jets
the other three wait till next year
i i probably more tempted to
drop this one into the wait till next
year if you're a head coach and you're
looking for a job because this may not
be a great spot for you right now what i
mean
need receivers that's not on the roster
the quarterback situation
need running backs defensive lines all
need to need new guys on there
linebackers are underwhelming
safeties are nothing special corners are
okay
teams got a lot of work that's where and
then to me mike the other thing when you
just talk about taking it over
too and the quarterback situation i i
mean that's got to be
part of who you hire as a coach you know
i know jeffrey luery made some strong
comments about carson wentz and
you know i expect him to be the guy we
drafted him and he want nobody wants to
win more and win more for the city of
philadelphia
i i mean i don't know that that's the
big question does he really want to win
for philadelphia at this point
i mean i wouldn't be surprised if like
carson wentz was like ah no screw you
philadelphia i want out of here
so that too has to play into this
and if you're a guy that's looking to be
the head coach of the philadelphia
eagles
that's certainly going to be part of
like do i want to take that job and the
other thing i'll just say about it too
is
you know you'd like to figure out this
situation too
because if you do go with jalen hurts
you know
you have to build your team to fit jalen
hurts
that's a different team than carson
wentz you know jalen hurts i think you
got to go the way of almost like
hey we're going to play a little bit
lamar jackson ball and baltimore ravens
you know man he's not as fast and and
quite as dynamic as a runner but he's a
really good runner
but i think you go ball in with that
kind of hey he can run he can throw
we're going to be a double threat type
of offense
to where you would want a coach that
fits that too so
that's why i look at it and go this is a
little more complicated this job than
it looks at first
it's amazing it was only nine days ago
that on
uh the last football night in america of
the regular season i explained that what
the eagles plan to do was get some
distance from the season and then make a
decision about what their quarterback
position will be will it be an open
competition
between carson wentz and jalen hurts
will they reinstall carson wentz the
franchise quarterback making more than
30 million per year without question
or do they just say jalen hurts here
it's yours
take it and i still agree with your
observation that the the decision to
pull jalen hurts from the second half of
the washington game
at some level may have been motivated by
ensuring that he doesn't secure the
victory and thus in turn a presumption
that it's his job week one of 2021 but
now that
analysis unless they already know who
they're going to hire
that analysis is complicated by the
looming interviews where i think
question one tell me what your plan is
what your
vision is to continue to use the
buzzword that's emerged in the lurie
peterson
conversation what's your vision for our
quarterback position
what do you envision show us film show
us some play
designs that you have which guy would
you use do you advocate trading the one
that we don't keep and you know if if we
believe
that carson wentz and doug peterson had
a relationship that was fractured beyond
repair those were the three words that
chris mortensen added to the
broader context of that relationship if
that's true
well peterson's gone so
i know whatever it was that was
bothering carson wentz
should be gone now unless wence was just
pointing at the closest guy right as the
manifestation of his discontent and now
that
that guy's gone well i'm still not happy
yeah
my relationship with harry roseman is
fractured beyond repair
and then they fire him well my
relationship with jeffrey lurie is
fractured beyond repair
i i want to know what carson wentz
really really wants right
and and uh and look
this has got some houston texans quality
to it because
what the quarterback wants is relevant
what the quarterback prefers what his
vision is for his career
is relevant you can't give a guy that
much money and that mantle
and just say go sit down and shut up and
we'll tell you when it's time to come to
practice you have to be sensitive
to to how he's going to react to who the
new coach is
and what the vision for him is so this
is not
that's a tough one look i i would always
keep the lombardi trophy close by as a
reminder of better days
because better days these are not for
the philadelphia eagles no
no it's this is uh i mean it's become
one of them
like the stories to look for here in the
offseason right now
the eagles and just everything what are
they gonna do at head coach what are
they gonna do about the quarterback
situation how they gonna flip their
roster over
all of that uh it's uh i mean
they're they're in a tough spot and like
mike i thought about exactly what you
just said when i first heard the news
yesterday
like was that a is that a move was that
a move to
make carson wentz feel better did this
have anything to do with carson once at
all
or it was just this just a total doug
peterson thing and hey we'll deal with
you know carson wentz separately but
you're right i mean we i heard that
report with chris mortensen in week 17
that certainly didn't seem good but like
i don't think
you fire the coach if you think okay
carson wentz just doesn't even want to
be here in general so i'm not going to
fire him just
based solely on carson wentz so i
i don't know that's where i just look at
it and go do the eagles
have an inkling right now to go no i
think carson will be happy here in
philadelphia now that's doug's gone
or is this like a last-ditch effort you
know to save the carson run situation
or is it just something in totality
where there's a lot of issues
with doug peterson and they don't see
eye to eye with the organization
and they just felt like they had to move
on and now they're going to figure out
the carson one's thing on the fly
and that's what it kind of feels like to
me on the uh the last option i said
there
there is a chance that it is as simple
as this town isn't big enough for the
two of us
and one of us whether it's peterson or
wentz has to go
and the organization chooses the
quarterback
over the coach that's possible as well
yeah but we don't know
and who knows when or if we ever will
know what we do know is doug peterson is
now in the pool with all the other
candidates for the other
six vacancies that are out there we have
seen coaches get fired in one city and
land immediately
elsewhere we've seen super bowl winning
coaches have to sit out a full year like
mike mccarthy did
after he was fired by the packers before
finding his next gig
what do you believe is next for peterson
chris well
i think he's he's probably going to look
at the options that are available
right now out there as far as who might
want to hire him and
you know if his services are needed i
would expect i mean i don't think doug
peterson's any
i haven't heard anything where he's
thinking about stepping away from the
game or anything like
that so you know i would expect them to
be in the pool of the conversation here
about
you know guys that are linked to
different teams
but the thing that's going to be
interesting about that too
is the way it ended in philadelphia
nobody's just going to be like oh we got
to get doug peters in right now
because of everything we've talked about
there's a lot of questions that would
need to be answered
to make me feel comfortable as let's
just say an owner a gm
you know president of football
operations i would go wait that
philadelphia thing really seemed weird
it didn't end right
you got to do your homework and figure
out what really went on there
uh just to do to make sure you you feel
comfortable if you do want to hire a
doug peterson somewhere down the road
here
and let's think about that that's a
project that you would have to take on
on top of everything else you're doing
with your other candidates and there's a
point where you ask yourself do we feel
so strongly about doug peterson
yeah that it's worth slamming the brakes
on our search
because you know what happens once these
dominoes start to fall
and maybe they start falling as soon as
today maybe urban meyer was just waiting
for ohio state to play last night before
he took the jaguars job today
all i'm saying is maybe i'm not saying
definite i'm not saying probable
i'm just saying maybe but once these
jobs start to fill up
you get a little bit of a land rush you
get a little bit of anxiety
you know the music is starting to stop
are we going to get a good candidate
where is this going to go
teams may say we'll do our homework
about what happened between doug
peterson and philadelphia another day
we'll leave that to next year's
pool of teams looking for coaches it's
too much to throw on top of what we're
already doing
there's been some speculation about the
jets because joe douglas the gm was sure
philadelphia you know that's the most
obvious we do it all the time
we do all the time hey they they they
used to work together so they want to
work together again well sometimes they
have no desire to work together again we
don't know what the relationship really
is
and a point two points one
and this is stupid but teams think this
way
their last tire was who adam gase what
had happened to him he had just been
fired by somebody else we're not gonna
hire somebody who's just been fired by
somebody else again we're not gonna do
it again
it's stupid because it's two completely
different coaches but
sometimes that's a factor and the other
thing and this is weird inside baseball
kind of stuff inside baseball football
kind of stuff
bob lamont represents jo uh peterson
bob lamont likes to pair his general
managers and
coaches together right so lamont's going
to steer him away from the jets
if lamont's got a voice in this and one
thing we don't realize casual fans
even arden fans is a huge influence oh
huge agents
guys in different places in the
offseason yeah no no doubt about it they
are a big factor in all these decisions
that get made through these
organizations and like i think you made
the point with the jets right there
i think that's why it doesn't make sense
and it doesn't fit we just came with
like you just talked about
a guy who was supposed to be a good
offensive coach and kind of a
quarterback guru
and it was underwhelming when he left
miami and it just left off the jumping
spot to get on him here in new york
and i think that would be the same thing
here again too soon as he fails they'd
go
oh the offense isn't good and he what
did he do with carson wentz anyways and
that would be dangerous i would think
for the jets as an organization
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports